I'm absolutely ecstatic because this is
effectively a chance fulfill a lifelong
dream for me a chance to go into space
on a mission and to be an astronaut
which is almost every child's dream when
they're younger and for me a 10 mission
makes so much more sense than return
mission because we're not talking just a
short stay plan to flag and then return
this way by doing a settlement mission
straight away we can build a lasting
legacy for the human race and that's
what really motivates me to do this and
a lot of people raised some doubts about
whether or not this this mission is is
at all feasible they also have some
concerns about its safety as well do you
have any worries well of course there's
risks and his warriors with any space
mission but what makes Mars one a great
mission is that because there's eight
unmanned precursor missions before the
human missions this is actually the
safest mission in history don't forget
that the apollo module that landed on
the moon in 1969 was never tested on the
moon before it landed so of course
there's risks button yeah there is much
safer than it could be